Simplifica
"2a" cuadrada
sobre "3b" a la quinta,
todo eso elevado a la cuarta.
Y aquí podemos usar la propiedad
que nos dice que si tenemos
"x" sobre "y" elevado a la potencia "n",
esto es igual a "x" elevado a la potencia "n"
sobre "y" elevado a la potencia "n".
Veamos que eso se cumple con el siguiente ejemplo.
Si tenemos "x" sobre "y" elevado al cubo,
esto es igual a "x" sobre "y",
por "x" sobre "y", por "x" sobre "y",
y esto es igual a "x por "x" por "x",
dividido entre "y" por "y" por "y",
y esto es igual a "x" cúbica,
entre "y" cúbica.
Es un ejemplo particular muy sencillo,
pero para que te des cuenta que esta propiedad se cumple y la puedas usar con confianza.
Apliquemos esa propiedad en nuestro ejemplo.
Aquí nos están dando "2a" cuadrada
entre "3b" a la quinta, todo eso elevado a la cuarta.
Esta expresión la podemos escribir como el numerador es "2a" cuadrada elevado a "a" la cuarta,
lo escribimos aquí abajo,
"2a" cuadrada elevado a "a" la cuarta...
voy a poner en azul este exponente 4...
"2a" cuadrado elevado a la cuarta,
dividido entre "3b" a la quinta...
"3b" a la quinta elevado a la cuarta...
elevado a la cuarta...
y ahora voy a usar la propiedad
de que si tengo el producto
de 2 factores elevado una potencia,
eso es exactamente igual,
a que eleve primero cada factor a la potencia,
y luego realice el producto.
Así es que esto va a ser igual...
déjame escribir esa propiedad por acá...
Si tenemos, digamos "x" por "y"
elevado a la "n", esto es igual a "x" a la "n",
por "y" a la "n"
y podrías desarrollar un ejemplo similar al que hicimos aquí abajo para convencerte de esta propiedad.
Vamos a aplicarlo aquí en nuestra expresión.
Esto va a ser igual a
2 elevado a la cuarta,
que multiplica...
que multiplica a "a" cuadrada
elevado a la cuarta,
y todo eso,
dividido entre "3b" a la quinta, elevado a la cuarta,
lo cual va a ser 3 elevado a la cuarta,
3 elevado a la cuarta que multiplica a
"b" quinta, "b" a la quinta
elevado a la cuarta.
Ahora aquí también hay algo interesante,
pero vamos a evaluar los coeficientes primero.
Tenemos entonces en el numerador es 2 a la cuarta,
2 a la cuarta es, 2 al cuadrado es 4, 2 al cubo es 8,
2 a la cuarta es 8 por 2 = 16.
Vamos a ponerlo aquí esto es 16 y 3 a la cuarta,
3 al cuadrado es 9
3 al cubo es 27,
3 a la cuarta es 81...
3 a la cuarta es 81.
Vamos a escribirlo aquí, déjame hacerlo con otro color, voy a ponerlo con el mismo verde,
y para evaluar estas expresiones podemos usar la propiedad del producto de los exponentes.
Si tengo un número elevado a un exponente, y a la vez elevado a otro exponente,
se hace el producto de los exponentes.
Veámoslo, si tenemos "x" elevado a la potencia "n"
y a la vez está elevado a la potencia "m",
esto es igual a "x" elevado a la potencia "n" más "m".
Así es que,
¿cómo queda nuestra expresión?
En el numerador tenemos 2 a la cuarta que ya calculamos que es 16,
que multiplica a
"a" al cuadrado elevado a la cuarta,
y esto es "a" a la 2 por 4,
que es igual a "a" a la octava.
Esto salió de multiplicar...
vamos a ponerlo aquí,
multiplicamos 2 por 4
y nos dio el 8 el exponente
y eso dividido entre...
eso dividido entre 81
que multiplica a "b" a la quinta
elevado a la cuarta,
esto es "b" elevado a las 5 por 4,
que es "b" elevado a la 20,
este 20 salió de multiplicar 5 por 4.
Hemos concluido,
la hemos simplificado a su mínima expresión.